hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from round three of the
of the Allen Doris a be rapid tournament
in the previous two rounds a Larissa
Fallujah lost a game to 11
Aaron him but also drew a game against
England from a seemingly completely lost
position and he core Nakamura won in the
first round against Erica Kerrigan and
drew in round two against Daniel DuBose
so now in round 3 we have Nakamura
versus Fallujah and it is quite the game
so without further ado let's check it
out now Kimura with the white pieces
opens with E for story opens with D for
future goes for Knight to f6 with Knight
to f3 and d5 now and now I'm not going
for the c4 yeah idea immediately but
first III the Col system we have eats
eggs by future for now a very very
symmetrical and b3 now Hikaru plants the
finger after his darts for the shop over
over here and then put the bishop on d3
so both bishops will target the Kings
side we have Bishop to e7 and now Bishop
to b2 now so just continuing development
if you lose your castles and now Bishop
to d3 we have b6 now fallujah also wants
to be in care to his LightSquared bishop
and he called just castles with the shop
to b7 and Knight B to d2 now preparing
the rope might come to see one you can
play c4 so it's a very natural
development of pieces we have c5 by
black also very natural and now a 3 we
have Knight to c6 and here there is one
game where Knights the if I was played
but here and Nakamura goes for the
captures and c5 right away he unleashes
the the full power and glory of the
bishop pair and it is as of move 10 that
we have a completely new game so B
captures and c5 by the by doing this
early capture he gives a future a lot of
control well over over the central
squares and now c4 he doesn't want to
allow Fugit the Box in any of his
bishops but also if you go for d4 now to
try and keep the dark square Bishop out
of commission then just captures
captures and for the moment you do have
upon on d4 but it's hard to say for how
long as
a lot of pieces attacking at the Queen
is sort of x-raying at b4 b5 can be
played to kick off one of the defenders
so it's very unclear so instead fiddle
jogos a5 he wants to play a four and now
C captures on d5 with ich actress and e5
and now Queen to c2 putting some
pressure on the c5 phone but also on the
h7 pawn we have a four asking do you
want to capture here and then allow me
to push c4 also might be an idea
although it's very unclear after Bishop
to f5 what what will be blacks planned
here but the doubled apon shouldn't be
much of a problem for black so Nakamura
instead goes at rook 8 d1
I just continues development and now a
capture Sun be three we have night
capture Sun be 3 now Nakamura captures
with a threat of just capturing on c5
with the night and here you don't really
lose a piece with c4 if c4 now then
white simply captures it as you're
unable to recapture and due to the pin
however it's not a bad move because even
after Bishop captures on c4 you have
Bishop captures on a three characters
captures and the game continues with
equal material but instead future
decided to defend the pawn with Queen to
b6 but this doesn't work in fact it's it
doesn't work at all so feel free to
pause the video here and try to figure
out what Fallujah missed while playing
Queen to b6 well I'll give you a couple
of seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations unsporting
that you can remove one of the defenders
of the c5 pawn and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show and of
course also the h7 pawn it's Bishop
captures on f6 now if Bishop captures
you not only win the h7 point but also
the c5 pawn so here future decided to go
for G captures on f6 but now Bishop
captures on h7 with check and his King
side kind of falls apart so King to h8
and non Knights to h4 nakamora wants to
bring the Knight to f5 to put pressure
on the bishop on e7 so Knights the e5 by
future getting the knight to help out
with the defense but still Knight to f5
is now the best
is also undefended and it's very hard to
find a move here for example if you
capture the bishop then just captures
with check and after you block the check
with Nigeria just Knight captures and c5
is very strong
you want some material and also there's
a lot of pressure here rook the rook to
b1 is the threat and well black is black
is completely lost here but there isn't
a well there are better moves but not
much better move Fallujah played rook
captures on e3 on a3 he decides to give
up the e7 pawn for the b3 pawn but the
the e7 I hope for the b3 night but
Nakamura is not interested in this
rather he goes for the he immediately
goes for the kill
so once again pause the video and try to
find the the winning idea for white well
or rather the the quickest winning idea
for white well I'll give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who are able
to do it congratulations on spotting the
the mating idea and for those of you who
just wanna enjoy a show its Queen to e
to and now there is no defense against
Queen to h5 whatever you play you might
try let's say Queen captures on b3 the
obvious reply just Queen h5 and the
knight and Bishop prevent the King from
going anywhere next move whatever black
place doesn't really matter it's just a
quick checkmate
the bishop g6 checking has to move check
and now either Queen g7 or Queen to h8
will be checkmate and other than that
you could try an IG 6 but still just the
Queen h5 and it's the same idea the King
cannot reach the G file I just Bishop
comes to g6 with or without capturing
doesn't really matter and it's the same
mating pattern so after Queen to e2 now
if you lose you decided to go for rook
to a4
that's unclear as to why it doesn't seem
to be it doesn't seem to be doing all
that much but ok probably maybe it was a
mouse slip or something but I doubt it
maybe maybe he was just trying to keep
her eye on the g4 square for some reason
or something but all-in-all nakamoto
just went Queen to h5 and it was in this
position unmoved 21 that Alireza fuchsia
resigned the game and
brilliant victory for Hiro Nakamura a
twenty one more victory in in a rapid
game so it was all about that Quinta
Queen to b6 move which is which is very
funny
because if you think about it after this
night captures on b3 you kind of
instantly play see for even if you even
if you blunder that you cannot recapture
I mean do you can do to the pin but
still it's it's the best move in the way
to go and of course alavesa try to
improve on the best move
and then blunder the game away but it
happens to everyone so there we have it
so yeah that's around three we're gonna
check up on a few more games from from
the first four rounds and then we're
gonna check out the standings before we
head into into the second day of the
island or SMB rapid tournament so once
again I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank Pratyush Shahani Nicolas
total is a script reader care Paul sonda
and JC Lopez for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Lindo
race tournament checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and of course
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day